hello everyone I'm Grandmaster Denis
Porsche and this is the most beautiful
era of all the Romantic era and today
I'm going to introduce a legend a tragic
hero then fine called him all of his
games are like John Keats poems all
tragic and unfulfilled beauty obviously
I paraphrase there and also he played a
legendary world champion Emanuel Oscar
and after losing the game he said I will
have to play this younger man once more
for the world title he was a Hungarian
and Czech citizen as well so he later
became a Hungarian citizen so his name
is Roger Cossack he he is from a Czech
ancestry but he always proclaimed
himself as a Hungarian in fact there's
movies about him chap movie called The
Golem and first I'm going to show I hope
that's the first game I will show you
yes is the legendary game there he faced
the world champion among all Oscar now
the other thing I wanted to tell you
about Karl sack dad he learned chess at
age 15 and this is played eight years
later so eight years later after
learning how to play chess he defeats
the reigning world champion that's not
bad so e4 e5 and if I tell you that this
is the Romantic era
guess what kuru suck played here
yes f4 he takes f4 and now I've looked
at many games in this time period the
1880s from 1900s mid 1900s and not
everybody guesses the right right moves
here but karasek actually chooses the
best move in this position ejected Lee
the best move
yes Knight f3 no yes no not d4 Bishop c4
yes and it's according to Fisher as well
and note B in 1896 and kuru sec plays
the best the best move in the Kings
gambit which is which is something I
promise you he didn't have a computer he
didn't cheat trust me
so d5 obviously Lasker is no slouch she
plays the best move takes Queen h4 check
which is a little bit off actually
you're supposed to play Knight f6 Knight
c3 Bishop b4 lots of games here you know
people who play this with white was more
savage Bronstein you know people you
barely heard of all right so that's the
main line but Queen h4 check is a
reasonable move right I should we
continue with white yeah can get one
yeah kinky to just looks funny and will
block everything so King F 1 is just
reasonable g5 Knight f3 Queen age 5 and
kuru SEC keeps pounding away will not
stop until
he just crashes through against La
spirit
how did Kasich continue here so actually
the one of the most basic principle of
the Kings gambit is attack the f7 pawn
actually that's the deep concept of
whole thing so how can white mount some
pressure on this f7 pawn what do we need
to get close to that point
tonight yes so we have what we want to
bring close to that pawn now you just
need to find the method yes h4 now we
just have to understand why is age for
any good now lost curve plays Bishop g7
first we have to understand why he plays
Bishop g7 our first question is
obviously and a g4 it
why not g4 them yeah not g5 won't I trap
your knight okay can't play f6 cuz that
would none into this nasty check and
you're losing and d4 end it's just
losing so black must lean at age six now
it's a big question here what should we
do now because this night does look
funny here a little bit so question is
if f6 from black is a big threat or not
well it turns out it's not because you
play d4 and if he plays f6 I can just
jump in here and there's no way of
capturing my Knights and if you come
back then I just take on f4 and if you
just take me I'm dominating you all of
my pieces will come in and I'm winning
there's no way you can deal with this
does that say 97 Bishop f4 and after
let's say Castle Knight c3 you're
paralyzed I just need to make my King f2
move and I'm winning which is quite a
feat remember Carew SEC is a young guy
playing the world champ so you didn't
play g4 obviously cuz he saw that this
will not work out well for me Bishop g7
and he plays Knight c3 now Oscar is
known to be a tricky guy can't even
capture that g5 pawn which is funny
you can't take because the Queen would
drop we can't take her the pawn cuz the
rook would drop so Carver sac prepares
the knight take with Knight c3 so notice
that there's a lot of thought in all of
these moves he could have played d4 but
that would achieve nothing would that
threaten taking on g5 not at all
therefore Carlos exercised okay so my
principle Knight c3 is the better move
c6
where should we bring our bishop this is
also kind of an important question
yet two options but he'll need a totally
different game
yes where would you bring your Bishop
and wine okay so you're saying you would
bring your Bishop to b3 because you
bring it to c4 it would be head by b5
mm-hmm anyone else any other thoughts
what would be the positives of Bishop c4
yes yeah you can't play Bishop e2 does
our King have enough shelter no we don't
so we need that extra guy to help us and
actually that's why we play Bishop c4
and in Cossack Rudolph Carlos I played
Bishop c4 we need that defender there
Bishop g4 and now d4 we played nine
moves without d4 that's Grandmaster play
ninety-seven and actually the next move
is probably the prettiest it's not like
an outlandish sacrifice but it's still
quite aesthetic
look for the harmony of the white pieces
is White's position harmonious almost we
all was there but not yet how can we
make this position even more harmonic
how can he makes me love happy
what's the ugliest piece in our position
what is the ugliest piece in the
position knight on c3 cook the ship on
c1 on anyone
what about the ruler what about the
ruler of all the ruler of all on f1 is
terrible King f2 and this is a very very
stylish move connecting both of these
pieces and suddenly for like moves you
didn't threaten to take on g5 suddenly
you have no more hope of holding your
position together that way if you take I
take I take on h4 and Bishop f4 and my
position is just beautiful
I have everything out your pieces are
all scattered around and I'm
positionally much much better so it
takes on f3 G takes after me and we
solves almost all of our problems
there's only one problem that white
faces and that's the king that we have
in the center we would be almost winning
the battle and you'll see that Cossack
will solve this easily we actually
threatened to take g5 but a problem is
because the queen is on h5h sticks
doesn't help because we take take and
then this pawn on f4 will be weak
forever
so he'll on castled and i will have to
find a thematic way of preserving the
advantage which karasek does really well
yes
'if five if we play e5 Knight takes e5
and we lose the game fro this position
is very tricky one bad step and we're
done with white well
what were we doing all these moves what
was our main plan when we played h4 to
take on g5 should do it now then take
now we achieved our positional goal we
have a beautiful center what we don't
want to get check mated with being g3
check so we might have to find a way to
solve that issue
yes 92 very good just taking away this
important g3 square also defending this
pawn and attacking the f4 one and you
can see blacks position is just falling
apart
why does few moves away from completing
development and if he does it's game
over fini 7c 3 now fini 7 is not a good
move because it's too slow
what black could have tried is to play
some like Knight b6 you move the Bishop
to b3 because we have no choices son and
also the bishop did in its due duty
before it was an option to bring your
Bishop to e2 and defend your King now we
don't need the bishop so the bishop can
go now
it's about to be a very very bad
experience for black if he doesn't do
something radical how can we get radical
here with black in this position
meaning going tall on this position that
black yes mm-hmm
Oh rook d4 is a bit much but Bishop
takes d4 Knight takes d4 yes and this is
not correct unfortunately and probably
Oscar knew this is bad for him
kinky too is a very strong move here and
miraculously the King feels really safe
there because if c5 you say I'm just
building my center of its c3 takes takes
and it's over and not have six takes and
even if you sacrifice is not enough and
you're losing you don't even go Bishop
d2 if I'm very scared but just to see
how sharp this is King f1 wouldn't be
soo too good
was it rugby for would work here take
takes you have to move the King here and
perpetual and thank you for having me as
if Turkey enough to I just take your
rook and suddenly you're dead lost with
white so this is one of the sharpest
positions possible at least in e4 e5 so
Bishop d4 this concept would have been a
bit more challenging for white even
though it's losing but Laska tries his
luck slowly tried to wiggle out but he
won't see 395 it's a cute little tactic
but it does nothing absolutely nothing
now
our king is kind of safe with white but
we still need to develop our pieces very
well to actually win this game with
white
what did food of Cossack play here
obviously black thread is simple
taking on c4 that's what he's trying to
do and we can't take with the pawn
because we're just pinned so that's not
an option
yes Queen a4 that's what Carl SEC plate
and I like this move honestly because it
follows the principle of if you see a
good move try to make a better one now
we all see Bishop b3 as an idea but then
we do one thing that we shouldn't be
doing being lazy and not trying to make
the best move possible with Queen a4 he
forces lost his hand and says okay are
you going to take my bishop or not if
not you're wasting time with your
Knights and also gave me free time to
develop my queen but if you do exchange
as he did I develop my queen I only need
to develop my bishop and it's game over
Knight f6 if you look around you look at
the audience we take the pawn on f4 and
we know we're going to beat lost care
because the only thing left would be
some Knight takes e4 tricks but it
doesn't work clearly it's just
insufficient like if you take I would
even consider like tricky ideas of rook
h3 and just sliding the rook to e3 again
you go here just cookie three and
bye-bye
and you have nothing here no play
against my king
she plays ninety seven and obviously we
can't state right now that white is
totally winning but it's not always easy
to win these winning positions so
karasek looks for an idea that would
stabilize his advantage
and if we think about what Knights love
most
we'll find Co sex plan yeah
yeah 93 heading to f5 he plays Queen a4
first Asics provoking he provokes that
weakness but then there are few moves he
does go nighty-night f5 but this was
mostly matter of taste he could have
gone that g3 immediately Nigerian Knight
f5 and this is the beginning of the end
we can all see that
96-95 being a fake ship g3 notice what
is in no rush of winning the game he
says I'm in full control I don't have to
do anything he could play Bishop e5 but
that would be something loss curve would
be dreaming of exchanging something off
and hoping but after Bishop g3 I have a
beautiful bishop and you have a
not-so-good on g7 so Bishop g3 rook d7
Knight takes takes me five now
exchanging pieces in a winning position
is not bad just make sure it's on your
terms and he realized that okay I'm a
pawn up so I can exchange everything and
especially keep a bishop against the
knight in this type of position Queen
takes e5 Bishop takes e5 f six because
sadly if the rook moves you just take on
h7 and it's game over f6 takes rook f8
brocade six and also notice that Carlos
SEC is not rushing and notice that in
many games people rush like they would
play e5 the e5 is not a good idea here
especially because you're giving the
chance for black to good go to d5 and
just have some counter play Cossack says
no no no no not doing that yet Knight f4
King III not g2 King d2 look f2 and when
the night is away he plays d5 Knight a4
rook H 1 mu g 8c for just creating a
little bit of lift so that king can
walk into safer places 96 King III night
at faith the five fifty seventy six and
seeing that the pawns are rolling black
resigned and this was the time when he
said at this moment when I resigned
against Carew sack I knew that I'm going
to play this man for the World
Championship in the future sometime in
the future
sadly that never actually happens
because Carl sac passes away in the
1900s because of a sickness and dies in
Budapest as far as I know yes and dies
at the early age of 26
now this was a good example of how kuru
sak plays very aggressively very
precisely and to be honest I think the
way he played is a good example of how
chest should be played in general
did I hear a question I thought I heard
no okay
alright so let's go to another game
played against the grandfather of
Russian chess chigorin before E 5 and
curse X stays true to his spirit and
plays the Kings gambit
he takes f4 Bishop c4 same thing and d4
Knight c6 is a ver option usually people
play d5 or c6 d 596 is read d4 Knight of
6 e 5 and here Chi Goren as he is a very
very strong player wonder he's called
like the grandfather of Russian and
Soviet chess he finds the best move in
this position
what did she go and play here any ideas
back there how could she Goran punished
white for playing a five so early he's
attacking the Black Knight but that
doesn't mean that she going will move
his Knights
he plays d5 which is a beautiful obey
classical concept in the 45 systems
black is not impressed by the idea of
taking this is okay so what you give a
check I'll block it and black is just
much better here because he has the
bishop there and black is just more
devil of them white so Carlos ACK brings
the bishop way to b3 Bishop g4 just
developing its pieces between d39 h5
which is like a bit of a stingy move
he's defending the f4 pawn but I'm not a
big fan to be honest like you get a bad
piece just for a pawn and it's usually
not a good deal and here again Carver
SEC shows how inventive he is and he
comes up with a concept that you don't
really see in modern chess I mean
sometimes you do but not that often
he plays Knight h3 saying oh sure you
wanna check me play Knight F - not a
problem
and his point is he's trying to
continuously attack the pawn and maybe
on a beautiful beautiful sunny day
attack the d5 pawn as well but we'll see
if he gets there so night before I think
chigorin likes his Knights too much he's
jumping around a lot here and if you
know the [ __ ] in system you know that
I'm not just blabbering away he does
like Knight moves a lot of them Queen C
396 and this is a bit too much it's
excessive fun by black the position is
closed so he's not lost but I think that
this was kind of wasting time he needed
to play like Bishop e7 and Castle and it
would be like a normal position
I'm not saying that white is better or
black is better I think this is just a
normal position with mucho chances for
both sides I think that b4 is just a bit
too creative 96 Castle Bishop e2 Bishop
a4 check
c6 and now Carlos egg goes all-in
Bishop takes c6 v takes Queen takes King
g7 we'll just have to find horse X next
move
so why did sacrifice a piece already but
look at those knights and if you
remember what they say about this
Knights we know that these are going to
be the end and they're grim and the
future for black should be grim as well
the question is how should we continue
with the attack
yep
that's what he plays matter for you
should bet for now yeah he doesn't care
about rooks he's going for checkmate so
white black plays eight six but funnily
enough takes the best move is a romantic
move obviously because it's an era it's
about the Romantic era so white to move
and play their beautiful idea actually
here
yes
ship g5 I have f6 for that at the moment
yes so Bishop g5 is the right idea but
not the right order
we can't really say that like it's too
developed here right I mean like has an
active King but that's all so I can't be
punished that yes
he's six that's a bit too early can we
check maybe one Queen are we seriously
considering winning with just a lone
Queen no we shouldn't
let's bring all the kids to the party
yeah yeah Knight c3 and the point is
Bishop g5 is a great idea just here if I
take even if I clean I'll be sad after
this move but but after Knight seats me
well first off this Knight takes d5 is
quite powerful
it's almost winning there and if you
move the bishop now now I have here
check takes and this is the big
difference that the bishop moved and
Kasich obviously knew that this is in
the air so the knight c3 is quite a
beautiful idea six late age six Knight
c3 still not bothered Bishop c4 e6 he
played e6 now because Bishop g5 is
already taken care of we can't use that
d6
rook c8 and now karasek plays a
beautiful move
yeah ship d6 I can still take on these
eggs
even though I think that's also really
good
he played Bishop c7 and this is just a
massacre bishop season is a beautiful
Bishop d6 I think is also really good
but Bishop c7 is very stylish because it
takes
I take check King d8 and now Cossack has
a deadly deadly moving yeah rook d7 and
saying okay I'll take it now check well
we can take everything or if you want to
and can play Queen d7 on checkmates so
Bishop c7 played F takes c6 between was
taken and rook f7 comes they should be
seven okay obviously Chico and they're
still trying but to no real avail be
three takes and here he realized that
this attack is just too strong all right
so we've seen two fabulous games by
rudolf carl sec but let's go look at one
of the famous one of the most famous
games by carlos actually so e4 e5 and
for a change you're going to look at a
different opening and cossack played
something else play d4 c3 the Danish
gambit and if you notice it's 1893 car
SEC actually was a huge innovator he
might actually be the first one playing
this system I'm not sure about that but
it's highly possible talking about
Cossack he invented this system it's
named after him
and been played by Tigran Petrosian
Karpov Kasparov cars and to top all of
its everybody just so you know that
Carew SEC even though he plays brilliant
attacking games he was a very innovative
player and probably a genius so it's a
pity that he couldn't play over a
championship match against Oscar so deep
for coming back to the game c3 he takes
c3 remember you're in the Romantic era
you're not in the era where I play d5
and say oh I can draw this game somehow
so black goes okay it's another free
pawn let's take it Bishop c4 Knight f6
and it's just very exciting obviously
just because you're in the Romantic era
you don't go crazy and take everything
because then with these two bishops
staring down at you I mean you would be
legitimately scared
so Waller doesn't do that and plays
Knight f6 Knight f3
look how cosec doesn't care about the
pawn take my pawn take my phone he says
Bishop c5 and now okay he says I have no
choice b6 gas will cast it now often the
trouble with these gambits
is that you run out of attacks then you
have to resort to your own imagination
to find the way through and cossack has
an imagination and finds a way to blast
through the black defenses any ideas how
he tried to break down this barricade
that black built
yes
if five I just take you I'm a pawn up
I'm happy to every gift I'll take
remember romantic era
I'll take everything
Sakura SEC goes by g5
he's trying to get give a gift that you
cannot refuse now I think black makes a
big mistake here should develop the
night and it's not sure if this is going
to break through still I mean there's an
attack and white can try but I'm
pessimistic but after eight six cossack
starts firing the way knight takes f7
rook they accept some
and plays a very good move yes Queen b3
then I defend my rook yes
now e5 yes because if I would take you I
can kiss goodbye to my queen right so
that's not good
I have to move the knight but again
karasek was ready for an IG for
v6 yes the problem is you can't move the
rook because then I take you I take
everything yeah and I promote my queen
to your queen takes okay that's more
Mathura and we winning
we're just a queen up so Wallner for a
counter-attacking idea which is a little
scary but you know when we're scared we
take our opponents pieces so we take on
our seventh King f8 now first you should
notice what our opponent is trying to do
so we should stop it
now there actually many ways to stop it
then not surprisingly car ii finds the
best one any ideas how we should stop
that might be shipped back for it
well said Bishop f4 or thought Bishop at
work okay
who's that h3 nobody good good this ship
f4 is very good night except two if
Bishop f2 that does really nothing I can
just move my king and I'm up billion
pieces tonight they accept to and now
it's getting tricky because black will
be able to jump around with the night so
we need to find the right spot for what
for that White Queen
yeah we need to Bishop d7 will come next
check Bishop d7 Luke ae-1 because he's
getting ready to have some ideas knight
c6 and Cossack to move and finish in a
spectacular way
vini seven I take you so Queenie seven
is the right direction but not the move
yes ship d6 and Bishop d6
mm-hmm yes
Queeny eight that's what he played the
same concepts exact same concept Bishop
takes pawn takes checkmate
so this is one of the most famous Carver
SEC games and actually and result Asst
calls this um one of the best games ever
which I wouldn't disagree with because
this is beautiful
double checkmate with so many pieces on
the board that's very nice
now last but not least I want to show
game which he played against rector
who's a very very famous Viennese
Grandmaster who almost became a world
champion let's be honest there and the
way he plays in this game
I mean Carew sack is very high level and
I wanted to show that game and that's
why I think that Cossack if he would be
living it in our times he would be a
very strong Grandmaster in fact his
provisional rating that they would like
prophesize and in the 1900s or like the
early 1896 he was around twenty seven
thirty rated and I assume that's like
two thousand like based on the ratings
of two thousand and twenty seven hundred
is like top ten top 20 in the world so
that means it was a very strong player
and after you'll see this game obviously
the previous game was beautiful but this
one isn't bad either be for a five here
Bishop c4 so this time the Italian
Bishop c5 c3 I just wanted to point out
that he did play d4 in this position
against Fon popiel in a different game
but that's a different story
c3 d4 takes e5 now this is a very very
old line which was actually
invented by none other than Carew sack
and it's funny because people associate
Bishop e2 that Jo bhava was a very
strong player but this game was the very
first game where white men Bishop e2
which is astounding that's such a good
player played it and nobody noticed that
it was actually his own his idea 94 now
there's obviously this idea of Bishop b5
here here takes Bishop d6 and the whole
fight revolves around the fact that
White is trying to defend this d4 pawn
and attack the d5 pawn black on the
other hand is trying to undermine the
center at Bishop g4 and f6 there's a lot
of games going on in this line so Bishop
e2 which I think deserves an exclamation
point for the efforts from the 1900s 94c
takes d4 this should be six Castle
Knight c3 Bishop g4 Bishop e3 now it's
all the same thing but the bishop is
very well placed on e 297 classical play
many many grandmasters will do the same
right now
97 and here Kosek starts to play
somatically how can we get bit of this
efore night that would make our lives
much much easier and curse x goes just
for that he plays Queen c2 attacking on
e4 now excuse me
black would take does take on c3 but
what should we do if black plays Bishop
f5
obviously we can renew the thread Bishop
d3 right
and as we're attacking with too many
pieces black will have to give away and
obey to our wishes so doctor decides to
take on c3 takes 96 and the reason I'm
just so impressed with this game is that
how creatively cossack plays and in fact
his next move is quite nice
it's more strategical it's not like
winning shot like as we've seen in the
previous game it's more of a builder
move building for future events so we
know notice that we have a king side
majority right we might need some more
space to be able to roll with our pawns
so how could we do that yes
ninety-one well it's a bit too passive
it's not a bad idea but it's a bit too
passive but you're looking in the right
direction we are trying to open up the
road for this f-bomb
yes now g5 very good bishop take c2
queen takes 82 h6 night h3 and I really
like this move because it says okay this
might look weird but hear me out
I'm going to go at 4 at 5 and checkmate
and all will be good
so at 5 again a good defensive move
maybe f6 could be an idea but probably
f4 and I'll just rolled you over after
at 5 so this is already not good news
for Spectre
so at 5 F for mean d7 B and C 2 so
already preparing something is actually
preparing to somehow break through it
and add 5 bush is it possible now
obviously not but look how Carlos egg
does it look at seven nine f2 there is
that night going not a fate where is
that guy going yes
well 93 that would be the logical move
but the Cossack has his own ideas and
that's why I actually put this game last
because I think that this is still one
of Cossacks most spectacular ideas yes
94 that's a bit much but it's more of a
strategic yes we're 9 h1 and what's the
idea
yes so the idea is very deep and I
didn't gave it double exclamation marks
but I think it would deserve it cur SEC
says ok I know my plan
you can't stop stop me so I have time to
put my knight to H 196 now G for first
is that my point is that if you take f5
and I just destroy you
especially that a fork is coming like
Knight g5 I take you and e6 and after G
fork he wants to do takes takes Knight
g3 and this is pure Grandmaster chess
seeing in front that this night is going
to be super useful in g3 so I just
prepare this put the knight on h1
obviously it's a closed position he gets
to do this don't do this in an open
Sicilian you don't have time for this
but here he envisions that this night
will be super useful on g3 and it does
basically destroys blacks concept black
is forced to go to the g7 because
otherwise the knight would hop to have 6
and that would be game over so factor
goes 97 King age 1
what is why planning now you already
moved the night to g3 but what does King
age-1 signal yes yes we're planning to
roam through the G line King a chip from
g1 g2 row b g1 c6 we need to no rush my
night is still kind of playing against
your night
so I don't want to move my night if I
don't have to because you're basically
paralyzed we need to move g6 now night
h5 this is the right moment because if
you take I bring my queen with the tempo
take sticks and this is again a very
nice move because here I say okay you
take in fact this is so good for a white
the white play was so good that Queen h6
actually wins here does rook age 7 it
just runs into maze
checkmate so that can't even take
immediately but then Queen takes g2 and
I pin you because if you take his
checkmate Michele D 8 D 6 pin take C 697
mean II 396 and like resigned because
this is a classic double attack you
can't defend against mate or losing the
bishop you can play Queenie for which we
are not forced to take you just take the
bishop and it's over you take and I'm a
piece up so it's over so this this was
Rudolph Roger Cossack one of the biggest
talents of that time at least in these
late 1900s
I mean late late 1890s 1900s
he was a great hopeful player and sadly
he passed away early but I hope I showed
you that
true potential and he was wonderful
chess player thank you
[Music]